Сандра не хоче, аби показували її обличчя.
Через страх перед чоловіком, який її роками бив -
знову і знову.
Коли він агресивно пішов на мене, мені стало по-справжньому страшно.
Потім він взяв шарф і скрутив його на мені.
Після того ввечері я подзвонила в поліцію,
і тоді мені стало зрозуміло: так далі тривати не може.
Мені треба від нього піти.
Сандра знайшла притулок в так званому жіночому будинку.
Три роки тому вона вже якось опинилася в такому притулку,
але згодом повернулася до свого чоловіка.
Як і багато інших жінок, вона дала себе вмовити, каже вона.
Також сподівалася на примирення через спільну дитину.
Коли хтось хоче піти, має зробити це один раз і назавжди.
Це моя порада усім. Бо коли повернешся,
то все стане лише в рази гірше.
Аби привернути увагу до проблем таких жінок, як Сандра,
жіночий будинок розпочав кампанію -
розвісили плакати з написом "Гідність жінок недоторканна".
Меседж жінкам: не бійся, звернися до нас, ми допоможемо.
Що я хочу сказати іншим жінкам:
не бійтеся, робіть цей крок, просіть про допомогу,
ви її отримаєте.
Я не знала, де я можу отримати допомогу.
Я просто залишалася вдома і чекала,
що хтось прийде забрати мене з цього пекла.
Для жінок працює також цілодобова гаряча лінія -
анонімно і 17-ма мовами.
Однак лише кожна п'ята жертва домашнього насилля звертається сюди.
До нас звертаються жінки, які зазнали нападу щойно або вчора чи позавчора.
Але також звертаються жінки, чиї історії тягнуться вже роками
і які ще ніколи ні з ким про це говорили.
Побита та принижена партнером -
така картина не пасує до образу сучасної, впевненої у собі жінки.
Через це багато жертв соромляться відкрито говорити про свої страждання.
Але щодня з насиллям стикаються занадто багато жінок,
аби про це мовчати, причому в усіх прошарках населення.
Уже тривалий час до жіночих будинків у Німеччині
звертається більше жінок, аніж у них є вільних місць.
Бракує фінансування. Нещодавно німецький уряд
виділив додатково 41 мільйон євро
для жіночих будинків та кризових центрів.
Це лише перший крок - потрібні й інші.
Як тільки з'являється вільне місце - воно одразу зайняте.
Ми мусимо відмовляти багатьом жінкам.
Приміром, у 2017 лише у землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія
відмовили 7400 жінкам через нестачу місць.
Для Сандри місце в жіночому будинку було справжнім порятунком.
Без підтримки вона не змогла б вирватися із замкненого кола.
Найгірше було, що я повірила своєму чоловікові.
І найкраще - що я тепер нарешті змогла зробити цей крок
і піти від нього і тепер заново починаю своє життя.
Уже незабаром Сандра з дитиною хочуть переїхати у власну квартиру.
Жахливі спогади ще наздоганяють її.
Але вона намагається тепер дивитися лише вперед.